leur armée est infinie, nous sommes 40,
nous avons les 47 contre des centaines, ce qui est une
excellente action, donc il y a des flèches qui
repèrent votre jeu d'épée, il y a eu un
réel effort pour connecter les combats à l'
histoire que
vous vouliez obtenir autant de caméras que nous
pouvions des combats ce n'est pas  votre
père film de samouraï ou combats de samouraïs
j'apporte cet élément de regarder l'été
j'apprends les dix oies ou les techniques que
vous travaillez haut-bas en
essayant de pénétrer à l'intérieur du
piano de canard de canard et j'ai eu un combat en tête-à-tête
c'était  un gros combat ses styles
plus sauvages et les vrais Kai sont plus sur les
coudes d'attaque facilitent les coups de poing
scrappy gagnent à tout prix nous voulions montrer le
contraste entre son style et mon style
Sanada fils joue un machiniste haut la
main la barre haute
est un maître épéiste
dans l'historique  l'attaque des
quarante-sept Ronin dans lesquels ils se sont faufilés la nuit
et ce n'était pas une énorme bataille, ce que nous
voulions faire était quelque chose de différent pour
avoir une plus grande échelle, donc nous avions
tout de 47 hommes infiltrant un
château et se battre contre des centaines,
puis les combats en tête-à-tête, ce vrai
combat et cette grande action
[Musique]